Let's look through the options.
This one is likely to save way more versions than you really need.
But even if you're only actually saving when there's been a change over
the course of the hour,
you're likely to save at points that don't make a lot of sense.
What if you're in the middle of typing a line?
Your saved versions might not even compile,
much less make sense as a logical checkpoint.
This option does have the advantage that if you tend to be forgetful, and
not save often enough on your own it can give you more fine grain detail than
you would have had.
But otherwise, there's not much reason to make this choice.
Okay, let's look at the second one.
This has some of the same problems as the above, and
you might get versions that aren't actually usable.
Plus, if you write a critical three line change one day and
then don't touch the code for a week, your change doesn't get
recorded until after you've made some other unrelated changes.
What about this third one?
This one's a little bit more promising.
You'll probably get some changes that have some kind of logical meaning from
this strategy.
But, you might also get some not so meaningful ones that come up when you
have to go run to catch your train or go have a nice dinner.
Okay, so what about this fourth one?
This has the potential downside of user error.
Not saving often enough or
saving too often, but it also offers a lot of flexibility.